[Music]  licorice pizza is a story that wonders  what happens when two people who can't  be together can't avoid being near each  other this is faith that brought us  together oh creep alana is volatile and  unstable in her life what are you  thinking huh a lot of doesn't have her  life together alan brings home stupid  boyfriends all the time  and gary is grounded and self-motivated  but he's a teenager  so alana what are your  girlfriend it's plans  it's a film that has this beautiful  volley of power that rolls between these  two people in humorous ways  [Music]  this film tells a story of destiny and  the hardest years of a young life and  these two become stuck together pieces  i'm not gonna forget you just like  you're not gonna forget me gross  [Music]  [Music]  you